welcome to pi data global 2021 for
talked by marco edward
riley sorry if i master pronounce that a
senior data scientist at gusto
university of oxford
pandas maintainer author of nbqa and
since this is his time i'll
pass the mic over to him
hello everybody
today we're going to talk about ordered
logistic regression
so you may have heard of logistic
regression already
probably in the context of a
classification task
and a lot of classification tasks are of
the form where maybe you've got an image
and you need to predict what animal is
in the image
something like that and in these cases
the categories are completely separate
there's no sense of ordering between
them
but i'd like you to consider this data
set which i'm about to show you
i've got some data which i downloaded
from kaggle
these are responses to a survey
and i have a column which tells me the
level of education that people have
so the the highest educational
attainment
and then i have two columns indicating
whether or not they know the python and
our programming languages
so i'm going to try to predict their
education level
based on which programming language they
know
just because i thought it would be fun
but also
because if we look at our target
variable
then sure it's a categorical variable
we've got four different categories
but there is an order between them
so high school
is
comes before a bachelor's degree
which in turn comes before a master's
degree which in turn comes before a
doctoral degree
so rather than trying to predict four
completely different categories
we want to somehow recast our
classification task in such a way
such as to preserve or to capture the
ordering between the different groups
so how are we going to do this
well before
we get into it let's just do a little
bit of revision and let's revise the
categorical distribution
now the categorical distribution
is parameterized by
a vector of probabilities
so suppose
we have
the categories
uh 0 1 and 2.
these are just totally arbitrary
category labels
let's say
i don't know
whatever they can mean whatever you want
them to mean
and you want to say that you want to
impose that the first category has got a
let's say 30 chance of being picked
the second one has got a 50 chance of
being picked and the third one has got a
20 chance of being picked
then this is how you would specify that
with a categorical distribution
and if we take a sample
then
the most likely outcome will be class
one
that's uh we need a random seed here so
i'm just going to put the cell number
which i have that's how i like to set
random seeds
and here we got class two and that was
fun wasn't it so let's do it again
if we
take let's say 100 samples then you see
we get a mix of the different classes
and the most common class which we got
was class one
because that's the one that's got the
highest probability of being picked
and if we looked at the proportions
then the
the observed proportions should converge
towards these probabilities as we
increase the number of samples that we
take
cool so that's the categorical
distribution out of the way
let's get back to our problem there's a
question from eo about what is the dist
module
oh thanks yeah that's just uh
numpyro.dist so i just imported where is
it somewhere here numpyro dot
distributions as dist that's where it
comes from
well uh what is known byron pyro is a
probabilistic programming language
and uh yeah that's what i'm using here
to specify the problem
i've just moved the chat to a different
window so now i'll be able to see
the
um
whoops so now i'll be able to see
people's questions
and my notebook at the same time great
yeah thanks for your questions
so yeah let's carry on let's get back to
our problem so we've got a category
categorical distribution which is
parameterized by a vector of
probabilities
so it might be natural to think
let's just
try to predict the probability of each
one of these classes being picked for
each respondent
although then we go back to the issue i
brought up earlier which is that if we
do that then we haven't captured the
ordering between the different
categories
you know for the categorical
distribution the labels are totally
arbitrary
so is there a trick we can apply in
order to
capture this ordering
well
let's see
let's define
class 0 to be high school
let's define class 1 to be bachelor's
degree
class 2 to be master's degree and then
class 3 to be doctoral degree
then
let's define p0 to be the probability
that a respondent belongs to class 0
so the probability that a respondent has
got a high school degree
p1 will be the probability of class 1 so
bachelor's degree
p2 for class 2 and likewise for p3
then let's do a little trick let's take
cumulative probabilities
so let's define q zero to be the
probability of class zero
then q one will be the probability of
plus one or class zero
q two will be the probability of class
two or class one or class zero and
finally q3 will be the probability of
class 3 or class 2 or class 1 or class
0.
and we only have class 0 plus 1 class 2
and class 3 so q3 is guaranteed to be
equal to one
great
now if we
if we know the values of these different
queues
can we recover the values of our
different p's
let's open that question up to the
participants if anyone could suggest a
way of recovering the values of these
p's
if they know the values of cues then
please write it in the chat
how different would it be to use numpy
random methods or even create a mappable
function
and then fetch the labels randomly
yeah that's nice question perhaps i'll
get to that one at the end
um so yeah
yeah we can do subtractions nice one
so indeed
we can find p1 by doing q1 minus q0 then
p0 would be q0 minus zero which is just
q0 etc
and p3 will be q3 minus q2 and i went
ahead and straight away substituted q3
equals one
i also left padded the zero because this
shows us that if we have our vector of
q's and we left padded
if we left pad it with a zero and right
pad it with a one
then if we just call numpy.diff
then we will get back the vector of ps
now
we said earlier that q3 is guaranteed to
be equal to one
so we don't actually need to bother
predicting it
we only need to bother predicting q0 q1
and q2
and as we just saw if we know those
that's all that we need in order to
recover p0 p1 p2 and p3
so
how do we predict q0 q1 q2 and well just
q0 q1 and q2
because these are probabilities
and probabilities are guaranteed to be
between zero and one
which is a bit inconvenient when we're
trying to predict them
i'd like to be able to predict numbers
that are just unconstrained just
unconstrained numbers that are somewhere
there on the real number line
so what's the transformation that i can
i can apply to these numbers
such that they will end up being
somewhere on the real number line
again let's open this up to the chat
to the audience logit yes
indeed if we apply the logic
transformation which just as a reminder
is so the logit of p is the logarithm of
p divided by one minus p
then
that would indeed give us a real number
for each one of these queues
nice
so we'd like to predict these logits
using our features which are whether
participants know python and whether
they know are
so if we
have some model of these features that
gives us a prediction
then
we can define some cut points
which will be like the logits plus our
prediction
and we can put priors on
some of these parameters which
um which which we've specified
and then we can do a full bayesian
inference to find them
if this was a bit confusing then don't
worry we'll now see it in code and we'll
see the implication
the implications of the model which
we've just written down
so here's this little definition of a
model which i've written ordered
logistic regression
so let's start at the bottom we've got a
categorical distribution
which has this vector of probabilities
which we're trying to predict
we saw earlier that we can find these
probabilities just by doing a diff of
the cumulative probabilities
and we saw that these cumulative
probabilities need to be padded to the
left and to the right with 0 and 1.
then we get these probabilities by doing
the inverse logit
also known as x bit of our logits
and then our logits are equal to this to
some cut points
which
we seek to find here i've just put some
prior on them
minus a prediction
and the prediction is made based on our
features
so it's just the linear model we've got
a coefficient for whether a participant
knows neither python nor r
we've got a
coefficient for if a participant only
knows python
we've got another coefficient for
if a participant only knows r
and finally there's a coefficient for
if a participant knows both r and python
yeah so cut points encode our prior
knowledge it's kind of difficult though
to set these uh cut points based on
prior beliefs like i don't really have
any prior belief about what the value of
my cut points should be
and this is where prior predictive
simulation comes in handy
because we can try to see what our model
thinks
before it's been conditioned on the data
we can try to see what the model already
thinks it knows
and once we're satisfied that it's not
too opinionated
or that its opinions don't contradict
domain knowledge
then we can predict we can train it on
data and we can make
predictions so i've not filled this in
i've not filled in the fires
so we said earlier that we don't have
any
particular domain knowledge for what
these priors should be
so the typical thing that's done in this
situation is to set pretty wide
uninformative priors
so uh if anyone who's
got some familiarity with bayesian
influence wants to suggest a prior
um to put here in the chat we need a
value for the
mean and the value for the standard
deviation
if anyone wants to suggest one in the
chat i'll use that otherwise let's just
put zero and a hundred
uh where are we
all right so let's see what this implies
i'm going to do a prior predictive
simulation so before even training on
any data i'm going to consider four
fictitious respondents
one of whom knows
neither python nor are
the second one only knows r
the third one only knows python and the
fourth one knows both r and python
and we'll see what education level this
model is going to predict for these four
respondents without having seen the data
yet so it's only going to use the priors
which we have set here
so let's see what our model thinks
okay this is a bit strange
so for each participant the model is
extremely confident that for each level
of education
the probability of the respondent having
that level of education is either very
close to zero
or very close to one
the model is not really giving much
weight to intermediate
values
so that's a bit strange isn't it
we started off with very flat and
uninformative priors
thinking that uh like this we would end
up with an unopinionated model
but we've ended up with a very
opinionated model who's already got some
strong convictions despite not having
seen any data yet
yeah that's a bit strange and why is
that
well the reason is that
we have a non-linear transformation here
we're putting our parameters through
this inverse logic function
and just because the parameter is flat
in the parameter space
does not mean it's going to be flat in
the outcome space
and in this case
actually setting a narrower prior for
our different coefficients and for
the cut point
cut points
will yield a less opinionated model
which actually gives a bit more
probability to intermediate values so
that's nice
now that we're satisfied that our model
hasn't started already with some very
strong convictions
let's actually show it the data
let's uh
train it on the data and then let's see
how it opinion how its opinions change
once it's seen what's in the data
now this uh it's going to take a few
seconds to run
if anyone here is used to doing machine
learning and you're used to having
models that run on 10 000 points really
quickly
then you might find this to be a bit
slow
however
bear in mind that here we are not just
predicting
a single value we are actually going to
end up with a distribution
here
we're going to sample
1000 samples in four chains so we'll end
up with 8 000
values so once we've got an entire
distribution we can actually quantify
our uncertainty and it gives us much
richer information
okay let's look at the chat while this
runs
so mu equals one standard deviation
equals one oh sorry i missed that um i
put mu equals zero standard deviation
equals one so i just put a standard
normal does it run on gpu or cpu yes
so here i'm running it on cpu but if you
look at the documentation there are
instructions for how to run numpyro on
gpu
and uh it's already pretty fast on the
cpu
so
that's good enough for this use case but
yeah manpyro is amazingly fast
i really recommend it
right let's wait uh another few seconds
and this should be done
there was another question which was
asked earlier which i said i would come
back to later
so
how different would it be to use numpy
to numpy random methods oh yeah so for
that little example i showed you earlier
then yeah we could have just used
numpy random methods but once we do ncmc
then we're going to need a probabilistic
programming language
so that's why i directly used numpyro
then uh q and a how different is this
mcmc implementation and pmc i apparently
has an awesome library
uh i've i i'm too much of an ignoramus
to know
the differences between how they
implement mcmc so
i'm afraid i don't know sorry
then what's your take on different
packages for bays out there stan versus
pi mc versus numpyro
uh i've not used stun
uh pine c is awesome so yeah recently
there's been some changes going from
version three to version four which i've
not been keeping up with
uh numpyro is blazingly fast and it's
got already implemented in it uh some
very some
nice uh transformations for order
logistic regression which i'll give us
a little
i'll uh
i'll show them later
so that's why i use numpyro for this
particular example
okay there's three more messages in the
chat let's take a look at them
uh so
why were the differences in the priors
uh sorry i can't actually see the whole
thing
of different category probabilities
given that the priors were the same ah
that's because of the non-linear
transformation
and
oh
unless you're talking about the
different respondents in which case i
think it's just uh
randomness
can explain why we're using jacks
today rather than numpy
numpyro requires you to use
jacks and uh yeah so my understanding of
hamiltonian monte carlo is that it
requires to compute derivatives so
that's why jax is really
convenient for that so yeah i believe
they do use the auto diff under the hood
um yes but i gave the same values in the
normal distributions yeah true i think i
just took 100 samples
though so 100 samples isn't that much so
there's going to be
some
stochasticity in which samples actually
get drawn
anyway looks like this has run awesome
so if we print the summary number of
divergence is zero vr hat is all one so
there's no big red flags at least not
yet we can then look at our posterior
and we can look at the posterior
distribution for our different
coefficients
so remember the higher the value of a
coefficient then the more uh the higher
the level of education that the model
thinks a participant has
so just for fun well actually not just
for fun because you can already read
them here
uh so perhaps i should have asked that
earlier i was going to ask you
which one of these coefficients do you
think is going to be higher
and
you can see
so the for each coefficient the mean is
above zero
but there's lots of uncertainty there's
lots of mass on both sides of zero and
having a posterior distribution allows
us to really appreciate this
the only one of these coefficients which
is reliably above zero is coefficient r
uh so yeah if someone knows r then this
model thinks it's more likely that they
have a higher level of education
especially compared to if they just know
python
i thought it would be funny to bring
that up at a python conference
i don't actually know our myself by the
way
anyway
it's important to not interpret this
causally you know there's been a lot of
talk of causal influence at this
conference
so it's not like knowing r causes people
to have a higher level of education
if you wanted to
improve the level of education in a
population then teaching everybody are
wouldn't probably not be a very
effective intervention
however if you've got some random
programmer who knows r and you have to
get guess their education level then you
well let's see what you should probably
guess
we can
repeat these plots that we made earlier
but we can make them for the posterior
distribution
so once the model has already been
trained on the data let's see how it's
its opinion changes
of these four participants
and
yeah look at that
so for r
it's the only one for which it puts the
probability of someone having a doctoral
degree well above 0.2
so
and it's the only one for which the
probability of a bachelor's degree is
this low
so in conclusion what have we learned
today
we've learned that when your outcome has
ordered categories
such as survey response or education
level and probably some other examples
which you can ask write about in the
chat
then
a good way to capture the ordering
between the categories is ordered
logistic regression
we saw how to implement this in the pyro
and for anyone seeing this for the first
time this probably looks really
complicated
however you don't actually need to do
this in practice each time
so there's a nice convenience function
here in the pyro called ordered logistic
you just need to pass it
predictor and cut points
and it will abstract a lot of the
complexity that you see here for you
the
the prior that i put here for cut points
is also not the best one that you can do
but they have a transformation for that
uh
let's see if i can find this i think
it's ordered some
simplex to order to transform
so
uh i mentioned earlier why use empire
for this example well the fact that it's
got this already implemented for us
is a really good reason
and uh yeah so if you're actually doing
this in practice just use their
convenience classes don't actually go re
implementing this from scratch each time
um i'll just uh
finish the conclusion then i'll get to
the questions in the chat
so resources if you're interested in
learning more about bayesian stats
so the the book statistically thinking
borderline life-changing book
really good introduction to the topic
then michael bettencourt's case studies
and if you support him on patreon his
podcast all really good he's got a case
study specifically on ordered regression
another podcast which i always listen to
don't miss a single episode of is called
learning bayesian statistics by alex
sandora
and finally someone mentioned playing c
example play and see earlier the ymc
examples repository on github has
excellent tutorials and examples of
bayesian inference so that's a great way
to learn
and finally
if you're interested in working on some
really interesting data science problems
and you're based in the uk
then please either speak to me here at
the conference about
joining gusto
or apply directly at guster.co.uk
jobs
right now let's get to the questions in
the two three minutes that we have
remaining
so
what these plots show could you please
explain them a bit more sure i presume
you mean these plots here
um
yeah i'm assuming it's these
oh sorry i've lost the chart here it is
yeah so we've got four participants one
who knows neither python nor r
one who knows just r one who knows just
python and one that knows python and r
so what we're visualizing here is
what predictions would our model make
for these different participants and
what
predictions would it make for the
different education levels
and seeing as we're dealing with
distributions for each one of these
we've actually got the distribution
which captures the model's uncertainty
oh sorry you say you meant the density
plots yeah i presume it's these
i love the idea of order the
disaggregation cool
me too uh thanks a lot where can i find
this notebook uh yeah if you look at my
github um just github.com marco
guerrelli
there's gonna be uh there is already a
repository just called pi data 21 by
data global 21 something like that and
this is in there
oh hi ian thanks marco cool you're
welcome
right there's three questions let's see
if we can get to these in two minutes so
can you show us how to use this new
implementation of the logistic function
in such a way to get the same results as
your jupiter notebook
um
oh okay sure
i'll quickly
show you how to do that i think we've
got time so you would just
replace this part
with so here you would put ordered
logistic
and then you would pass predictor equals
oh of course the prediction
and then we've got something else which
is cut points
equals cut points
and then you can
you can ignore this part here
so yeah much simpler
this part in particular really
tricky to get right so it's nice that
they obstruct it for you
cool done that next one i took a job
test that was asking for all the
logistics based on categories couldn't
do it thanks for the tutorial what is
the links to the notebook yeah if you
look at me look for me on github you'll
find it could find some nutrition which
priors to choose and with which effects
do prior predictive simulation uh and
look at the effects it's really
difficult to imagine when you've got
non-linear transformations what the
effect of price is going to be and the
only effective way i found of doing that
is prior predictive simulation
can you show your references again
please sure and that's uh all the time
we have there you go
but you'll find the references if you
look for me on gittin
yeah
thank you very much marco you're one of
the you're definitely the most active
talk i've had by far
uh
you have a one you have a wonderful day
and uh
thank you
triple thank you for
coming for
and speaking at the conference
cool thank you so much for hosting me
and have a nice day